November 3rd we're putting together a
team
[Music]
no idea
in this film we wanted to kind of strip
it back and wanted have more fun with it
you know I'm tyka had the exact same
idea and we were both saying installed
ragnarok it's trying to have more
attitude ragnaroks sort of a new cycle
from the light of the world all the
realms of the universe it's the
destruction of the old' and the rebirth
of the new that's really exciting to me
surprise this will be such fun the way
that I've approached this is to rebuild
it in a new way look great dude
only I think it's just perfect mix for
where the character and story need to go
in our different costumes different
weapons different cost or characters to
work or give you a different energy Thor
is in a crisis he never went back to
Asgard to claim from he wanted adventure
when we pick him up he's at the end of
this search for himself will be once we
survive this trip I'd say the odds are
about a million fun
[Music]
you know I wanted to take people on a
ride and and pincette some comedy into
it an adventure that keeps people
laughing along the way
it also has inspector color on the stuff
that it gets people time he's a fighter
you know how to fight I want please
listen sound right hello goddess a death
is invaded as god I'm going to stop her
alone no put together team
he's a fighter
as a single new
revenge's revenge us we don't have to
have a name
we could have no name for right now Rock
get tickets now
you